Hi, I'm Hannah Dickinson and
this is "Cheers To You" where
I'm kicking off my first round
of the weekend by cheersing
to all the people and stories
that encourage me to drink.
Cheers to you Buffalo Wild Wings
on your new pumpkin spice wings.
Now, basic white girls can eat
and not have to force
themselves to throw up.
Can't wait.
Cheers to you Tara Reid for
getting booted off an airplane.
Sucks that you're going to be
late to literally nothing.
Cheers to you Nicole Kidman
for revealing that your marriage
to Tom Cruise saved you
from sexual harassment.
That's the beauty
of sleeping with gay men.
No matter how much I drink,
I never wake up sore.
Cheers to you Post Malone
for going undercover
for a charity stunt
literally fooling no one.
A real transformation
would require a shower.
He looks stinky.
Cheers to you Ariana Grande
for dumping Pete Davidson,
but keeping the pig that
doesn't make jokes about you
on Saturday Night Live.
I'm very sorry
about the whole thing though
and I love
Saturday Night Live,
and if you guys
would read my packet
it would really do
a lot for my career,
and I love you, Pete,
and I hope you're doing okay.
Cheers to you FDA on banning
Viagra spiked vape juice.
Not because it's dangerous,
but because it's pointless.
Please go back to the crème
brulee flavor
and your mother's basement.
Cheers to you people
at Six Flags who made $300
for lying in a coffin
for 30 hours.
That's the first time
anyone at Six Flags
has ever made $10 an hour.
Cheers to you
A$AP Rocky for being bullied
at 13 during an orgy.
I was also bullied
during an orgy.
A woman stopped me
from taking off my clothes
and said,
"Ma'am this is an Olive Garden".
They have unlimited breadsticks
and it's a lot
of white trash people,
so I feel at home.
Cheers.
Wow. That was a great
addition of "Cheers
To You" with Hannah Dickinson.
You can watch our regular show
Every Damn Day,
full episodes of it on the
Comedy Central YouTube page.
This week we talk about stuff
like the best episode
of Key and Peele of all time,
South Park sneak peeks,
and we even did a break
down of the hottest
Halloween trends.
Are you (bleep) joking?
No, we did it all.
We did all that.
You're going to sit there
the whole time.
You didn't laugh at one thing.
I live here on the set.